with a declining tendency toward
religious faith and a depleting trust
and sense of individual significance and
systems of community meaning culture
economy and state facilitated in large
part by the increasing proximity to vast
amounts of information many of us see
ourselves as inconsequential specs
destined to pass from dust to ashes with
nothing to show for it
in some sense this may be true
however there is one unique source of
profound scientific based significance
that we all possess no matter who we are
and what we do
without the requirement of any grand
illusions of achievement or faith in
anything beyond everyone you i everyone
we know and everyone everyone knows is
born with this woven into the very
fabric of our relationship with reality
we wear it in every moment and it cannot
be taken off not even by ourselves
it is the fact that each of us will
change the course of everything
forever
let's consider for a moment that time
travel were possible and you went back
in time some significant number of years
if while you were there you affected
something changed something influenced
something to go differently stopped or
started something that would have
otherwise happened or not and so on even
with just seemingly tiny insignificant
alterations it would be highly likely
that you would dramatically change the
course of events throughout history
thereafter
the preceding future would become
potentially a completely different one
or at the very least a notably different
one
most of us accept and understand this it
is the concern fear or premise of a vast
majority of films books shows and so on
that include time travel as a plot
device
we recognize that affecting a small
thing in the past can dramatically
change the present but yet we rarely
think about how affecting a small thing
in the present can dramatically change
the future
right now without time travel as an
option reality still works the same way
in every present moment your actions
interactions influences stopping and
starting of things and so on in some
likely sense change the course of the
future
not every little thing we do always has
a major impact on the course of events
but many likely do and we do many things
both big and small all the time
this process of how seemingly tiny
insignificant changes can lead to huge
consequences is explained by what is
known as the butterfly effect part of
the branch of science and mathematics
known as chaos theory chaos theory deals
with systems known as chaotic systems
that react with high sensitivity to tiny
changes in initial conditions and
through chaos compound and lead to the
generation of completely different
unpredictable outcomes in later states
of the systems
chaos is sort of a misleading term
because this process is not truly
chaotic in a random sense chaotic
systems function according to the laws
of motion physics and deterministic
principles like everything else but
because of their immeasurably complex
factors and high sensitivity to minute
variability in the initial conditions
they are just nearly impossible to
predict and appear chaotic
examples of chaotic systems include the
weather aspects of the brain population
dynamics ocean turbulence traffic flow
aspects of the economy and so on and of
course reality as a whole is a chaotic
system it is the total sum chaos of all
the chaotic systems combined the most
chaotic system a system can be and of
course we are in this part and parcel of
it
as a simplified example consider a
scenario in which a person is living
with a roommate at around noon this
person becomes hungry and decides to
have a meal from the options available
at their apartment this person decides
to make a tomato salad and they use the
last communal tomatoes in their
apartment later that night their
roommate plans to have someone whom they
are dating over for dinner and intends
to make a pasta dish with homemade
tomato sauce before their date arrives
they realize they're now out of tomatoes
and go to the grocery store to get more
when going to checkout by mere seconds
they get in line in front of another
person while checking out the cashier
mistakenly puts in the wrong code for
the tomatoes and must clear out and
re-input the code the transaction
totaling about three minutes
while on the drive home the person who
was behind them in line now delayed by
three minutes just barely happens by a
car accident that had occurred only a
short moment earlier this person who was
in line happens to be an off-duty emt
and after noticing one of the car
accident victims on the ground
unconscious they pull over get out and
provide the victim cpr ultimately saving
their life
this now rescued car accident victim
just recently having gotten married goes
on to live a normal life and have two
children with their wife
eventually one of their two children
goes on to become highly successful in
the medical field and creates the
formulation for a life-saving medication
as a result thousands if not millions of
lives are saved by this medication
allowing more lives and families to
continue and be born
further events would then continue on to
and through these new individuals
affecting more events and leading to
more people and things building and
compounding over time into a massive
webbing of sprawling cause and effect
interacting with other chains of cause
and effect along the way all still
interlinked with that original tomato
salad
of course all of the events even just
the initial delay of the emt required
many many other places where slight
changes occurred according to other
causes but ultimately based on the
butterfly effect the effects of that one
roommate deciding to eat a tomato salad
would at least in some varying degree of
causality continue on until the end of
humanity perhaps the world and perhaps
beyond
it is not uncommon to hear that one
wants to change the world it is the
tagline to so many people's dreams and
aspirations it's a noble and virtuous
enough ambition arguably we should want
to focus our efforts on intentionally
doing as much good in the world as we
can trying to change it for the better
because perhaps the more people who try
the odds increase that it might
but ultimately if one small action like
eating the last tomatoes can potentially
change the entire course of events in
the future what makes us think we could
ever truly know the impact of our other
actions
on the time scale of history good bad
and neutral events can never be fully
known or identified
but what we can know is that our
existence although a seemingly
insignificant fluke in a blip of time
through the butterfly effect will flap
out and leave its trailing legacy with
potentially increasing dramatic effect
for possibly the rest of history and
perhaps beyond chaos theory takes away
the long-term predictability of our
actions but gifts us back a perpetual
role in reality's operation
your legacy albeit indirect and
anonymous will continue
it is a flame whose fuse is anything in
existence
this contemplation isn't a resolution or
a placement to having a tangible direct
sense of purpose through the day-to-day
responsibilities of a job a career a
passion a family a friendship and so on
but it is to potentially serve as a
supplement for when in those moments
when some of the weight seems to
suddenly drop out of these things and
they feel illusory futile or temporary
and we question if anything we do
ultimately matters beyond us if we mean
anything to anything else in these
moments we can remember that at least in
some sense we do
so much
more than we would probably even like
in the final analysis either no one
matters at all or everyone matters
completely there is really no in between
no matter who you are because of you the
course of reality's future will play out
in a unique way we are not only each the
agents of our own story but we are also
the agents of the story of humanity this
earth and perhaps beyond collaborating
on the unique expression of art that is
the future
[Music]
this video was sponsored by
curiositystream
for those who appreciate
thought-provoking educational content
but still want to experience the same
entertainment and engagement as watching
their favorite shows and movies
curiosity stream is the streaming
platform for you
providing thousands of documentaries and
non-fiction titles from some of the
world's best filmmakers in subjects like
science technology nature history and
much more curiosity stream is the
subscription streaming service dedicated
to the intersection of our desire to
learn and our desire to forget that we
are learning while we are with enriching
beautifully produced pieces like digits
featuring vertasiums derek muller david
attenborough's light on earth and
transhumanism by jason silva curiosity
stream offers titles featuring some of
the most notable and familiar faces
voices and minds in the field curiosity
stream is available worldwide on many if
not most platforms and is extremely
affordable if you're interested you can
go to curiositystream.com
pow and use promo code pow pow and save
an additional 25 off the already low
subscription price bringing the total
down to just 14.99 a year or 125 per
month an unbelievable price for the
value again please visit the link in the
description and use code pow to sign up
today
and of course thank you so much for
watching in general and see you next
video
[Music]
you